Les llevaré hasta Bangladesh sólo durante un minuto.
Antes de contarles esa historia, deberíamos hacernos una pregunta:
¿Por qué existe la pobreza?
Quiero decir que hay mucho conocimiento y avances científicos.
Vivimos todos en el mismo planeta,
sin embargo existe aún muchísima pobreza en el mundo.
Y creo... quiero plantear una perspectiva que tengo,
para que así podamos evaluar este proyecto, o cualquier otro, al respecto,
para ver si está contribuyendo o...
a aumenta la pobreza o a aliviarla.
Durante los últimos 60 años los países ricos han estado enviando ayuda a los países ricos.
Con todo, ha sido un fracaso.
Pueden ver este libro,
escrito por alguien que trabajó en el Banco Mundial durante 20 años,
y a quien el crecimiento económico en este país le resulta difícil de alcanzar.
Con todo, no ha funcionado.
Por lo tanto la cuestión es, ¿por qué es así?
En mi opinión, hay algo que aprender de la historia de Europa.
Incluso aquí, ayer iba por la calle,
y me indicaron que hace 500 años tres obispos fueron ejecutados,
aquí mismo, al otro lado de la calle.
Así que mi idea es que ha habido grandes luchas en Europa,
en donde los ciudadanos fueron empoderados por las tecnologías.
Y exigieron a las autoridades...
que se bajaran de sus pedestales.
Y al final, se establece un acuerdo mejor
entre las autoridades y los ciudadanos
y las democracias, el capitalismo... todo floreció.
Pueden ver, el proceso real de...
y esto está respaldado por un libro de 500 páginas...
que las autoridades descendieron y los ciudadanos ascendieron.
Pero si observan, si tienen esa perspectiva,
pueden ver lo que ha ocurrido en los últimos 60 años.
La ayuda en realidad ha hecho lo contrario.
Ha empoderado a las autoridades.
Y como consecuencia, ha marginado a los ciudadanos.
Las autoridades no han tenido motivo para promover el crecimiento económico
para que pudieran aplicar impuestos a la gente
y recaudar más dinero de la actividad de sus empresas.
Porque lo estaban recibiendo del exterior.
Y de hecho, si ven a los países ricos en petróleo,
donde los ciudadanos no están empoderados, ocurre lo mismo.
Nigeria, Arabia Saudí, todos esos países.
Porque la ayuda y el dinero procedente del petróleo o la minería actúa igual.
Empodera a las autoridades, sin activar a los ciudadanos...
sus manos, piernas, sus mentes, y demás.
Y si están de acuerdo con eso, creo que lo mejor para mejorar esos países
es reconocer que el desarrollo económico es de la gente,
por la gente, para la gente.
Y ese es el efecto de una red de verdad.
Si los ciudadanos pueden trabajar en red y organizarse y hacerse más productivos,
para que se oigan sus voces,
entonces las cosas mejorarían.
A diferencia de esto, pueden ver la institución más importante del mundo,
el Banco Mundial, es una organización del gobierno,
por el gobierno, para los gobiernos.
Fíjense qué diferencia.
Y esa es la perspectiva que tengo, y ahora puedo comenzar mi historia.
Por supuesto, ¿cómo empoderarían ustedes a los ciudadanos?
Podrían existir muchos tipos de tecnologías. Y una de ellas es los móviles.
Hace poco The Economist lo ha reconocido,
pero a mí se me ocurrió la idea hace 12 años,
y en ella he estado trabajando.
Hace 12 años intentaba ser un banquero especialista en inversiones en Nueva York.
Teníamos... bastantes colegas conectados a través de ordenadores en red.
Y éramos más productivos porque no teníamos que intercambiar floppy disks;
nos podíamos actualizar más a menudo.
Pero una vez se vino abajo.
Y me recordó un día de 1971.
Había una guerra in mi país.
Y mi familia se mudó de la zona urbana, donde vivíamos,
a una zona rural lejana que era más segura.
Y una vez mi madre me pidió que fuera a por una medicina para un hermano pequeño.
Caminé 15 kilómetros, toda la mañana, para llegar allí, al hombre de las medicinas.
Pero no estaba, así que tuve que caminar toda la tarde de vuelta.
Así que tuve otro día improductivo.
Mientras que estaba sentado en un rascacielos de Nueva York,
junté esas dos experiencias,
y básicamente llegué a la conclusión de que concectividad es productividad
ya sea en una oficina moderna o en un pueblo subdesarrollado.
Naturalmente... eso supone
que el teléfono es un arma en contra de la pobreza.
Y si es así, entonces la cuestión es
¿cuántos teléfonos teníamos entonces?
Resulta que había tan sólo un teléfono en Bangladesh
para cada 500 personas.
Todos esos teléfonos estaban en las pocas zonas urbanas.
En las inmensas zonas rurales, donde vivían 100 millones de personas,
no había teléfonos.
Así que imagínense cuantos meses o años de trabajo se desperdician,
como yo desperdicié aquel día.
Si multiplican por 100 millones de personas, digamos que pierden un día al mes,
por ejemplo, ven una cantidad inmensa de rescursos malgastados.
Después de todo, los países pobres, como los ricos, tenemos una cosa en común,
y es que sus días duran lo mismo: 24 horas.
Si pierden ese precioso recurso,
algo en lo que eres igual a los países ricos,
es muchísimo gasto.
Empecé a buscar alguna prueba de que,
¿de verdad la conectividad aumenta la productividad?
Y no logré encontrar mucha, la verdad, pero encontré este gráfico de ITU,
que es la Unión Internacional de Telecomunicaciones, con base en Ginebra.
Demuestran algo interesante.
Ven, el eje horizontal es donde colocas tu país.
Así que Estados Unidos o el Reino Unido estarían aquí, fuera.
El impacto de un sólo teléfono nuevo,
que está en el eje vertical, es muy pequeño.
Pero si vuelven a los países pobres, donde le PNB per cápita es,
digamos, de 500 dólares, o 300 dólares,
el impacto es enorme: 6.000 dólares. O 5.000.
La cuestión era,
¿cuánto constaría instalar un teléfono nuevo en Bangladesh?
Pues 2.000 dólares.
Si se gastan 2.000 dólares, y digamos que el teléfono dura 10 años.
Y si son 5.000 dólares cada año... son 50.000 dólares.
Obviamente era un chisme que había que tener.
Y por supuesto, si el costa de la instalción de un teléfono está bajando,
debido a la revolución digital,
entonces serían aún más espectacular.
Yo sabía poco de economía por aquel entonces...
dice que Adam Smith nos enseñó que la especialización conduce a la productividad.
Pero, ¿cómo se especializarían?
Digamos que soy pescador y agricultor.
Y Chris es un pescador agricultor. Ambos somos generalistas.
Lo importante es que podríamos sólo depender el uno del otro,
si nos conectamos.
Si somos vecinos, podría acercarme a su casa.
Pero entonces estamos limitando nuestra esfera económica a una zona muy pequeña.
Para expandirla, se necesita un río,
o una autopista, o líneas telefónicas.
En cualquier caso, es la conectividad lo que conduce a la fiabilidad.
Y esa a su vez conduce a la especialización.
Y esa a la productividad.
La cuestión era, empecé planteándome este tema,
y yendo y viniendo de Bangladesh a Nueva York.
Había muchas razones que la gente me comentaba
por las que no tenemos suficientes teléfonos.
Y una de ellas es que carecemos de poder adquisitivo.
La gente pobre aparentemente no tiene poder para compar.
Pero lo importante es, si es una herramienta de producción, ¿por qué nos preocupamos?
Quiero decir que en Estados Unidos, la gente se compra coches,
y les supone muy poco dinero.
Tienen un coche, y van a trabajar.
El trabajo les reporta un salario;
el salario les permite pagar el coche al cabo del tiempo.
El coche se paga solo.
Así si el teléfono es una herramienta de producción,
no nos tenemos que preocupar del poder adquisitivo.
Y por supuesto, y aunque así sea, ¿qué hay del poder adquisitivo inicial?
La cuestión es, ¿por qué no podemos tener algún tipo de acceso compartido?
En los Estados Unidos, tenemos... todo el mundo requiere de un servicio bancario,
pero muy pocos de nosotros desean comprar un banco.
Un banco intenta prestar servicio a toda una comunidad.
Podríamos hacer lo mismo con teléfonos.
La gente me comentó también que tenemos muchas necesidades primarias que satisfacer:
comida, ropa, vivienda, etc.
Pero de nuevo, es muy paternalista.
Se debe generar ingresos
y dejar a la gente decidir qué quieren hacer con su dinero.
Pero el problema real es la falta de otras infraestructuras.
Se necesita algún tipo de infraestructura para implementar algo nuevo.
Por ejemplo, Internet está teniendo un gran éxito en EE.UU.
porque había gente que tenía ordenadores.
Tenía modems.
Tenían líneas telefónicas, así es muy fácil aplicar una nueva idea, como Internet.
Y es eso lo que falta en un país pobre.
Por ejemplo, no teníamos formas de acceder a cheques de crédito,
pocos bancos para obtener billetes, etc.
Por eso me di cuenta de que el Banco Grameen, un banco para gente pobre,
tenía 1.100 sucursales, 12.000 empleador, 2.3 millones de clientes.
Tenían esas sucursales.
Pensé que podría instalar torres de comunicaciones y crear una red.
Y bueno, para abreviar la historia, empecé...
Me acerqué a ellos y dije,
"Quizás yo podría conectar todas sus sucursales y lograr que fueran más eficientes".
Pero, después de todo, ellos se han desarrollado en un país sin teléfonos,
así que están descentralizados. Por supuesto que podría haber otras buenas razones,
pero esta era una de ellas... tenían que serlo.
No estaban tan interesados en conectar todas sus sucursales,
y después... echarlo a perder.
Empecé a analizar. ¿Qué es lo que en realidad hacen?
Pues que alguien pide prestado dinero del banco.
Normalmente se compra una vaca. La vaca da leche.
Vende la leche a la gente del pueblo y termina de pagar el préstamo.
Es un negocio para ella pero es leche para todo el mundo.
Y de repente me di cuenta de que un móvil podría ser una vaca.
Porque podría pedirle al banco 200 dólares,
conseguir un teléfono y tener el teléfono disponible para todo el mundo.
Es un negocio para ella.
Escribí al banco y se lo pensaron un tiempo y dijeron,
"Es un poco una locura, pero tiene lógical.
Si piensa que se puede hacer, venga y hágalo realidad".
Así que dejé mi trabajo; me volví a Bangladesh.
Creé una empresa en EE.UU. llamada Gonofone,
que en bengalí significa "el teléfono de la gente".
Y algunos ángeles inversores de EE.UU. colocaron su dinero en ella.
Volé por todo el mundo.
Después de alrededor de un millón... me rechazaron en muchos sitios,
porque no sólo intentaba ir a un país pobre,
intentaba ir a los pobres del país pobre.
Después de alrededor de un millón de kilómetros, y una significativa...
sustancial alopecia, finalmente formé un consorcio,
que incluía a la compañía telefónica noruega,
que aportaba el "know-how",
y el Banco Grameen aportaba la infraestructura para distribuir el servicio.
Resumiendo, aquí tenemos la cobertura del país.
Pueden ver que hay bastante cobertura.
Incluso en Bangladesh, hay algunos lugares que carecen de ella.
Pero también estamos invirtiendo alrededor de 300 millones más este año
para ampliar la cobertura.
Bien, respecto al modelo vaca del que hablé.
Alrededor de 115.000 personas están vendiendo al por menor servicios telefónicos
en sus barrios.
Está prestando servicio a 52.000 pueblos, que representan 80 millones de personas.
Estos teléfonos están generando
alrededor de 100 millones de dólares a la compañía.
Y dos dólares de beneficio por emprendedor al día, da un total de 700 dólares al año.
Y por supuesto, resulta beneficioso de muchas maneras.
Aumenta los ingresos, mejora el estado de bienestar, etc.
Y el resultado es que, ahora mismo, ésta es la mayor compañía telefónica,
con 3.5 millones de clientes.
115.000 de esos teléfonos de los que he hablado,
que produce alrededor de un tercio del tráfico en la red.
Y en 2004, el beneficio, descontando los impuestos...
muy estrictos, fue de 120 millones de dólares.
Y la compañía contribuyó con alrededor de 190 millones de dólares a las arcas estatales.
Y de nuevo, nos encontramos con algunas lecciones.
"El gobierno necesita ofrecer servicios económicamente viables".
Esto es un ejemplo en el que las empresas privadas pueden ofrecerlos.
"Los gobiernos necesitan subvencionar a empresas privadas."
Esto es lo que algunos piensan.
En realidad, las empresas privadas ayudan al gobierno a través de los impuestos.
"La gente pobre son los receptores".
La gente pobre son un recurso.
"Los servicios resultan demasiado costosos a la gente pobre".
Su participación reduce el coste.
"La gente pobre carece de educación y no puede hacer mucho".
Están deseando aprender y son supervivientes hábiles.
Me ha sorprendido mucho.
La mayoría aprenden a manejar un teléfono en un día.
"Los países pobres necesitan ayuda".
Los negocios... esta compañía ha aumentado...
si al menos el 5 por ciento de las cifras ideales son ciertas, esta empresa
está aumentando el PNB del país mucho más que la ayuda que el país recibe.
Y tal y como estoy intentando mostrarles, en lo que a mí respecta,
la ayuda perjudica porque elimina el gobierno de sus ciudadanos.
Y éste es un nuevo proyecto con Dean Kamen, el famoso inventor de EE.UU.
Él ha fabricado algunos generadores de energía,
que estamos experimentando en Bangladesh,
en dos pueblos en los que el estiércol de vaca está produciendo biogás,
que hace funcionar estos generadores.
Y cada uno de ellos vende electricidad a 20 hogares.
Es sólo un experimento.
No sabemos hasta dónde puede llegar,
pero están en marcha.
Gracias.